bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans l'émission
si on parlait sport ce talk est
consacrée comme vous le savez à
l'actualité sportive du département
vous connaissez programme il y aura des
coups de gueule des débats et des duels
quatre chroniqueurs sont en plateau
aujourd'hui présentation de la dream
team en musique le premier membre de
cette dream team est un cycliste il
aiguille champion du monde de cyclisme
sur piste masters ce champion d'europe
en 2013 sera notre spécialiste cyclisme
aujourd'hui on ne le présente plus yann
dujarrier est avec nous bonsoir michael
encore yann ravi de vous retrouver
pareillement vous avez travaillez vos
fiches vous avez vous avez vous
travaillé pour griller tout est prêt ok
mon bar ferme à vérifier ça plus tard on
passe de l'autre côté musique il y
d'autres spécialistes handball
il est entraîneur de l'équipe senior
masculine de versailles les entraîneurs
de la team 78 il est également au pôle
espoir il a réussi à se libérer malgré
son emploi du temps de ministre
alexandre taillefer est avec nous vous
avez bien alexandre je vais bien un peu
mieux puisqu'on a mieux réagi ce
week-end et je tiens à remercier ceux
qui m'ont soutenu lors de la dernière
émission d'un ulm difficile dialogue un
multi remet en doute repasse à droite
musique c'est notre spécialiste rugby
dans la dream team de ce talk il est
l'entraîneur de l'équipe seniors du club
de rugby de plaisir il est toujours de
bonne humeur et ses alliés sont toujours
pertinentes bonsoir genlis bonsoir eagle
ravi de vous retrouver là de même
mais voilà ce que vous avez quelque
chose à ajouter pour être proposant des
solutions on pas en passe de l'autre
côté à gauche musique c'est le michael
jordan ou le magic johnson du sport
évinois on le surnomme l'encyclopédie
dans le département son cerveau a stocké
depuis plus d'une décennie tous les
résultats des matchs locaux basés
rigolote avec nous si je vous demande le
résultat de trappes contre versailles en
coupe de france début septembre
de partout victoire de versailles et 4,3
ou aux tirs au but voilà impressionnant
tout simplement on va passer maintenant
au programme de l'émission aujourd'hui
nous allons parler de baseball avec les
cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux
le cyclisme sur piste avec le duel
pervis contre bouger mais tout de suite
coup de projecteur sur le boxeur est
lent courtois adila hamouma dit c'est
samedi 2 avril à liverpool boxeur élan
courtois a dit lahm houmadi remettra son
titre de champion d'europe des poids
super moyens en jeu contre le
britannique colom smith à 35 ans a dit
la affiche un bilan presque parfait de
20 victoires dont 3 par k o
avec une seule défaite callum smith est
lui invaincu en 18 combats à 25 ans dont
13 par ko ce combat c'est la jeunesse
contre l'expérience l'expérience d'adil
hamouma dit va-t-elle faire la
différence sur ce type de combat
l'expérience prendra-t-elle le dessus
sur la fougue de la jeunesse
vous votez oui non oui à un petit un
petit duel entre vous alexandre est
allée jan un petit duel vont commencer
yayi alors moi j'ai l'hiver parce que
comme d'habitude très chaud donc pour
moi français qui concourent dans
n'importe quelle discipline belge est
entré en argument je souhaite qu'ils
gagnent non mais là je défends juste le
fait que j'ai pas trop d'arguments
justement ensuite vous connaissez mon
amour pour pour la boxe et ses diverses
disciplines et multi fédération et on
concourt pour être être champion
d'europe et c'est donc voilà j'ai pas
par contre voilà une chose est sûre
c'est que tu est certainement à ce
niveau-là de l'expérience peut faire la
différence oui sage et bien andré car en
tant que master je vais aussi défendre
cette
7 le plus vieux puisque voilà ce qu'on
est
parce qu'on est plus âgée qu'on va être
moins un monopole bientôt 40 ans et
bientôt car on voit passer là-bas
alexandre alesi alexandre moi je me
réfère au bilan au bilan le plus jeune a
pas de défaite a dit cahoon
supplémentaire pour les raisons d'âge
justement il est probablement en
meilleure forme que celui qui a 35 ans
et à peu près inévitable maintenant
certes l'expérience mais bon moi je
pense que la fougue de la jeunesse c'est
plus important que l'expérience qui
compte c'est la condition physique et
surtout cette capacité à mettre
tellement que les joueurs les
combattants chaos
à mon avis fait de lui plutôt le favori
maintenant à 35 ans je alors dans le
vélo chris hoy a été champion olympique
à 36 ans sur le keirin
voilà c'est de la façon dont il avait
couru la veille il avait fait ça par ko
vraiment une maîtrise technique une une
maîtrise physique donc voilà peut-être
que sur après voilà moi je connais rien
à la boxe donc voila et je vais pas me
change sur scène ils sont français n'a
pas un palmarès plus important que ce
jeune ça aurait été le cas j'aurais dit
ok peut-être as-tu pensé dans l exemple
alliant suffisant voir les résulats là
je me l'a pas forcément l'expérience de
des victoires quoi plus que je ne sais
pas si jeune que ça 25 ans c'est pas non
plus un bébé maintenant 25 ans voilà on
est quand même aussi en pleine force de
l'âge à 25 ans 1 donc est-ce que la boxe
on arrive plus tard surplus plus tard
est bien d'accord sur le tard non mais
j'ai du départ je m'étais si je m'étais
vert et je m'étais vert parce que c'est
un français et parce que je souhaite
je lui souhaite toute la réussite tout
simplement côté comme ça je souhaite
évidemment toute la réussite
évidemment mais bon après si faut faire
un petit pronostic
je pense qu'il est plutôt outsider là
dessus je pense maintenant des fois ça
peut une politique cendres a mis k o
yann je rejoue alexandre françois jose
je rejoue alexandre l'expérience je peux
avoir effectivement là je peux avoir
l'expérience tout avoir
un point positif mais seulement par
rapport au palmarès la boxe ça ça triche
pas quoi il y avait une seule balle
alors qu'il a quand même un palmarès qui
est déjà éloquent
je dis pas que l'ancien à 35 ans il est
pas beau mais que trois carreaux quand
même que trois cas au nom pourrait dire
nos clubs punchy d'un côté une salle des
fêtes une seule défaite lors il a
l'impression qu'il n'a pas zéro pour
jeunes en a pas de dirigeant
oui mais il a quasiment autant de
confort il a quasiment autant de combats
un peu de temps et avec une réussite
surtout à par k o
je pensais quand même que hannah ce
sport là il n'ya que la vérité est que
ça la vérité c'est le punch et je pense
qu'il le peut une chute sur le côté
justement vasile on en parle de cette
expérience
cela dit la môme a dit n'est-il pas sous
coté au final qu'une seule défaite dans
sa carrière il a certes mis que 3 ko
mais il n'a qu'une seule défaite c'était
en 2012 contre james degale on parle
beaucoup d ahmed el moussaoui des cédric
vitu des marines petit mais finalement
aldi là n'était pas le meilleur boxeur
français actuellement dans sa catégorie
oui est évident évidemment vu que c'est
un des meilleurs européens des meilleurs
mondiaux dans sept catégories
après ce que je tenais à préciser c'est
que malgré les dix années d'écart qui
séparent adila mohammadi et ce
britannique nous mais ils ont à peu près
le même la même année d'expérience dans
le
monde professionnel parce que dylan ne
s'élance et que dans une carrière pro en
2009 donc ça veut dire qu'il a
actuellement 7 7 en 7 ans derrière lui
exactement comme comme l'adversaire qui
il voir qu'il va rencontrer donc c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont à peu près le même
nombre de combats donc après c'est pas
forcément l'âge auquel il faut se
référer
c'est plutôt leur parcours et le
parcours est à peu près identique même
si adil à s'élancer beaucoup plus tard
dans la boxe professionnelle
donc voilà c'est ce que c'est ce que je
tenais et il a aussi un peu atypique
aussi sept à dix la ville atypique parce
que il n'a du terme professionnelle que
le statu quo comme comme on le voit a
comme on voit beaucoup en france
bah c'est quelqu'un qui se lève le matin
qui est directeur d'un centre de loisirs
à elancourt qui travaillent la journée
qui va s'entraîner le soir
heureusement la ville d'elancourt lui a
permis de se mettre en disposition de se
détacher et en chipant fin janvier
pouvoir se préparer selon de l'aja tout
voilà pendant deux mois et demi à chaud
ou là soyez sportif en france
mais contrairement aux allemands ou
britanniques chine il a pas se leurrer
statu quo forcément ce que justement ça
peut être quelque chose de positif pour
lui parce que mon avis elle sera
forcément il aura beaucoup plus la rage
est plus motivé étant donné qu'il est
dans de moins bonnes conditions voire
mauvaises conditions face à quelqu'un
qui est un petit peu dans le la et dans
le confort qui est dans la richesse est
qui qui donc manquera peut-être un petit
peu cette cette rage qui fait souvent la
différence notamment dans les sports de
combat c'est qu'un titre de champion
d'europe a aussi servi on sait que un
titre de champion d'europe mais aussi
entre guillemets une demi-finale
mondiale parce que le vainqueur aura
l'opportunité à l'automne prochain
surtout un moyen de passer à l'étape
suivante le vainqueur sera donc le
challenger officiel du champion du monde
wbc abadou jack devenir champion du
monde c'est l'objectif des 10 la houle
écoute je souhaite le défendre
maintenant objectif c'est les mondes
et je réagis resterait du moi je
resterai
dans le milieu à temps je ne fait pas
bon mon championne du monde
donc là on est je pense qu'on est bien
parti pour pour le faire être championne
monde c'est le graal pour un boxeur jan
non c'est le graal pour un sportif
simplement je cours encore après cette
année donc maintenant avec bien sûr que
c'est c'est l'objectif
optimum derrière quand on est quand on
est jeune ou qu'on n'est pas
professionnel donc je vais aussi aller
chercher un titre olympique et ayad et
des sportifs
la boxe est un petit peu particulier
voilà dans la boxe il faut être amateur
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir combattre
combattre aux jeux olympiques donc voilà
bien sûr que participer à un championnat
du monde déjà c'est quelque chose de
très très sympa être champion du monde
podium à bhl dont quand on est à la boxe
on est toujours sur le podium mais mais
voilà dans bien sûr que bien sûr quatre
champions du monde sait ça fait partie
des raids ça pourrait lui apporter la
reconnaissance ur sur la carrière qu'ils
mènent depuis depuis dix ans si on
compte ce qu'il a fait en amateur il a
eu aussi ce petit problème aussi basile
il ya cinq ans il n'a pas combattu
pendant deux ans suite à sa seule
défaite justement contre james degale en
2012 il n'a pas combattu pendant deux
ans parce qu'il n'a pas trouvé
d'adversaire tout simplement
c'est peut-être aussi la raison voilà
pour laquelle il faut peut-être croire
en ses chances
il a la rage tout simplement maillard
agit là et il a été patient c'est dur de
s'entraîner pendant deux ans sans monter
sur le ring parce que quand on est
compétiteur je pense que si on
s'entraîne et qu'il n'y a pas deux il ya
pas match le dimanche où il n'y a pas
une compétition le week-end c'est dur de
rester mobilisés il y arrivait donc je
pense qu'il va monter sur le ring samedi
avec énormément d'envié
non disent qu'ils s'étaient aussi hyper
on a vu leur parti pour pas mal d'années
son combat devoir avoir terminé parce
que vu l'âge qu'il a c'est pas sûr que
c'est l'année ou jamais selon vous à
quoi je pense que cela n'ait jamais
surtout que cette opportunité d'avoir un
finalement unifiera championnats du
monde ce qui ce qui en fait quelqu'un
qui va qui va vraiment mon avis donné
tout ce qu'il a contrairement à l'autre
qui s'est forcément qu'avec son âge il
aura une seconde chance ça ça c'est
quelque chose quand même
oui finalement qu' on est peut-être
derrière motivation on va être à pas
être la même peut-être et peut faire la
différence
après il y aura toujours quand même dix
ans d'écart probablement quand même un
physique peut-être un peu moins
endurants donc c'est plus le combat va
durer alors lequel physique moins
endurants le plus vieux ben en plus pour
moi le plus vieux aura un physique
beaucoup plus endurant que le plus jeune
et ça tu peux alors là je peux te
l'assuré dans beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de sport plus tu vieillis plus tu
deviens endurant
oui mais un autre là où je vous rejoins
non non non non non non je peux
t'assurer que là c'est pas du vélo au
premier on prend des coups mais tu les
encaisses tu les encaisse et ils n'ont
pas le même poids ils n'ont pas le même
poids et je peux t'assurer que tu
beaucoup plus tu t'es tu encaisses plus
facilement que facilement vieillissant
et ça
parce que l'expérience fait que tu
l'aies ils n'ont pas le même poids que
c'est un peu plus à peu près le même
poids avec son assistant la même
catégorie le poids des coûts à la non
pour moi pour moi l'expérience et
l'endurance jouera et plus combat durera
et plus le français sera sera en pointe
je mens je pense pas parce que tu
oublies la notion de coût et dans un
sport à limites d'endurance pur c'est
vrai que oui mais sauf que c'est pas
l'endurance pure puisque on prend des
coups donc que tu prends des coups
plutôt endurance va chuter
ça dépend où deux frappes sont aux
francos fois par exemple c est donc à
mon avis lui plus le match va compter
plus à savait donc sans voix alexandre
voir combien vous appelle il doit mettre
bientôt tout de suite de la lettre sur
l'adversaire cloud file du mois du moins
il va y avoir après le côté mental qui
va jouer parce que la fatigue physique
c'est aussi quelque part un dépassement
de soi donc on peut être plus fatigué
physiquement intrinsèquement avec un
mental tellement fort qu au final on va
tenir au delà de nos espérances malgré
le fait que l'autre peut-être plus +
enfants parce que plus jeune et donc ça
dépend voilà son côté un peu dernier
combat dernière chance avec objectif
derrière ça pour pour les mondiaux et
l'autre qui arrivait un peu forcément
dans sa tête il y les stades comme nous
donc forcément ça dit il ce sont à mon
avis un peu favori et et il sait que
dans tous les cas c'est pas son dernier
combat donc puisqu'il est propre à ce
qu'il y ait une organisation autour de
lille qui lui permettront indifféremment
des français de retrouver des combats
plus facilement
donc je pense que il ça peut être dans
ce contexte l'un à 50 50
c'est à dire sans smyth sur quelle
chaîne alimentaire voilà vous êtes les
informations y en avait je suis prêt à
regarder du coude au cas après donc
après cette page boxe on passe au
baseball
c'est désormais une tradition pour la
vingtième année consécutive les cougars
de montilly bretenoux ont organisé ce
week-end leur tournoi de pâques au stade
jean maréchal les fans de baseball saint
quentinois ont pu voir leurs protégés
mais également les jeans moeurs de saint
lô les saintes de saint germain en laye
et les outlaws de strasbourg le tournoi
de pâques bien qu'amical est avant tout
un rendez-vous pour permettre aux
cougars de préparer le championnat de
deuxième division la saison débutera le
dimanche 3 avril contre et sin le
tournoi de pâques a été remporté par les
cougars devant les scènes ce hall écoute
avec son couteau joueurs de montigny
cette année c'est plus un niveau
régional national une donc un petit peu
en dessous de notre division mais ça
reste quand même un niveau correct pour
pouvoir se préparer de bonnes façons les
cougars qui remporte le tournoi de
pâques c'est de bono qu une bonne augure
pour la saison de deuxième division je
rappelle que le tournoi était amical
vous votez oui non je vois partager
vasile bon basile de bonne augure étant
donné que c'est une équipe qui évolue en
deuxième division
heureusement qu'il y qu'il gagne j'ai
envie de dire si les autres équipes
engagées évolue en n1 donc c'est le
troisième échelon national et voire
régionale donc heureusement sinon ça
aurait été inquiétant avant d'aborder
avant de démarrer la saison
donc pour toi combien rouge partout
quand les adversaires sont plus faibles
rico heureusement qui gagne comme ça et
je connaissais quand les coaches géant
gens de vraiment inculquer cet esprit de
victoire parce que finalement sur un
tournoi amical
voilà il n'y a pas forcément un gros
niveau ou alive ou gagner ces matches là
pour préparer justement les prochaines
échéances et inculquer aux joueurs
justement cet esprit de victoire je suis
partie des entraîneurs qui déteste
perdre et tous les matches sont à gagner
match amical ou pas il faut les gagner
il faut les gagner c'est une compétition
à tout point de vue c'est un match
amical certes mais c'est une compétition
donc là je rejoins m aimait mes
collègues entre guillemets parce que
s'ils n'arrivent pas gagné
dans un sport comme le baseball alors
qu'ils sont largement au dessus ce
serait inquiétant pour leur préparation
donc on de bonne augure je suis pas sûr
qu'un c'est vraiment de bon augure
sportivement pour eux d'avoir gagné ce
tour même si c'est un mage m'étonne du
choix de tournon où il n'y a que des
équipes en dessous de leurs divisions y
aurait eu un mix entre dirigeants
veulent pas venir c'est plus amical
c'est plus que trois amicales oui mais
on peut en trouver un en organiser un
avec des équipes de notre niveau en
dessous voir au dessus mais la quelle
ils ont pas du tout 2 2 je trouve de
peut pas être assuré d'avoir gagné
puisque au contraire il aurait pu juste
être en dessous de tout mentalement s'il
avait perdu un match mais à être là être
assurée avec des divisions en dessous
non est de faire de temps en temps des
matchs avec 10 en dessous de les faire
que des masques diversion lors d'un même
tournoi
je me demande comment ils s'adressent de
cérémonies soufies et qui sauf s'ils ont
d'autres tournois où il y aura des
équipes plus fortes
voilà mais je l'aï déjà dit ce week-end
pas pour moi non pour moi si on recompte
que les équipes en dessous ça prépare à
rien après si on fait un mix entre
plusieurs niveaux
là oui parce qu'on peut juger pour faire
un peu joué plus les remplaçant par des
équipes un peu en dessous après une
équipe très forte
un peu comme nous pour nous
une équipe de plus beau voilà un mix de
tout mais à voir que les équipes en
dessous pour moi en prépa en rien la
saison cette année les cougars ont
effectué un recrutement intelligent et
astucieux avec notamment la recrue
américaine american aux rires ryan war s
alors certes d'origine california arqués
californienne qui a évolué en australie
la saison dernière le sportif devrait
être l'une des têtes d'affiché de
l'équipe cette année
il a marqué les esprits pendant ce
tournoi de pâques et même pendant toute
la préparation on écoute les réactions
là c'est marrant parce qu'il a envoy
vraiment qu'il est agressif dans le jeu
et c'est ça qui fait plaisir
après il a vraiment le style américain
vraiment joué le jeu ça qui est marrant
a bien lancé le premier match lundi 0
la semaine dernière à montpellier il a
réalisé une bonne performance contre une
équipe de notre division donc on est
vraiment confiant avec lui sur
denticules sera yen/euro ares peut-il
booster l'équipe selon vous on a déjà
les deux coéquipiers sont apparemment
très contrastées adversaire le premier
adversaire des nausées ce tracé par
celui coéquipiers et l'adversaire ont
l'air de dire qu' il est il et il est
très bon et donc le coéquipier dit que
justement il a fait il a fait déjà des
bonnes performances contre des équipes
de leur niveau sur la semaine dernière à
pauline à montpellier voilà dans le sud
donc voilà c'est quand même de bonne
augure et je pense que oui c'est ce type
de recrutement peu les peler bouchez moi
je mettrais un bémol parce que par
expérience je me fie des recrutements
des étrangers parce que bien souvent
pour justifier leur arrivée ils sont
super bons en préparation voire début du
début du championnat
et puis après ils peuvent s'installer
dans un espèce de confort un peu voilà
donc je dis pas que c'est son cas mais
je dis qu'il faut attendre un petit peu
plus longtemps mon avis pour juger
réellement de son apport et de ses
performances parce que ce qui compte la
compétition c'est la répétition des
performances
donc je vous rappelle son parcours il a
joué en division acier avec l'école
state university northridge il a joué à
berlin 3 elle dit jean l'australie à
canberra et en première division en
belgique
voilà son expérience peut peser vraiment
cette saison selon vous gens
certainement parce que les clubs ne m'a
rien dit mais je bats et les sens doit
jouer ça ne va jouer son expérience
parce que là les north shore il parce
que je pense
je passe de remporter vas-y vas-y son
expérience avec son pouvoir
déjà qu'il a fait non je pense que je
pense que j'en passe se contenter de
quelques performances importantes s'il
fait en arrivant est certain qu'on
arrive en avait pas dorer la pilule donc
se méfier que ce soit passé meilleure
performance de l'année mais qui continue
à être aussi bon qu'il a été apparemment
au début j allais dire je veux juste
faire elle veut dit le petit et
remarques non mais ça veut rigoler mais
c'est pas du tout mais ses performances
et personne ne le connaît pas et je
pense que c'est un bon joueur je suis
comme hubble mais je remets ça un petit
peu à l'échelle en france par exemple au
rugby on dit souvent que les gars qui
arrivait chez en région parisienne avec
l'accent du sud c'est forcément des bons
joueurs pour certains lacs salés jolie
longuet tulasne aux joueurs aux huit
super bien des fois c'est des trucs
géniaux mais parce qu'ils ont la ksa
c'est un super joueur
alors messieurs nous mêmes des
américains qui arrivent avec des clubs
et je suis à dire oui moi j'attends
j'attends j'attends de voir quand même
ce qui doit nous aider à le voir jouer
du coup et bien si j'ai l'occasion oui
vraiment vraiment de saison qui commence
le 4 ème ri de moi peut-être avril parce
que pour moi on y arrive sur la fin de
championnat en c'est comme le foot us
c'était voilà c'est des saisons qui
égale ok voilà c'est dur qu'à six mois
ça finit en juillet parce qu'il à cause
des décisions d'ici montjoie
là commence la saison et l'hiver il est
à avoriaz ils desservent
mais c'est vrai que prudent c'est un bon
exemple avec les templiers d'elancourt
en foot américain
on a regardé chaque pour l'instant les
résultats ne sont pas là et ça porte à
une plus value forcément l'équipe
ces recrutements tant pis on écoute
justement rennes le reste mais explique
pourquoi il a posé ses valises à
martigues 1 pour une bonne équipe nous
avons une super semaine de stage la
semaine dernière à montpellier j'ai pu
voir l'expérience de l'équipe
le groupe qui était en place et j'ai pu
voir que j'avais pris la bonne décision
en venant ici
il a l'air motivé en tout cas alexandre
encore appelée aussi la sève qui tire la
gueule à feu n'a rien non c'est normal
qu'ils soient comme je vous ai dit c'est
normal qu'ils soient à la nuit de bon et
est évidemment motivé
maintenant attendons de voir la saison
les matches qui comptent c'est très pâle
et non pas les matches qu'on joue en
effet bois illégal contre les contrôles
et nationale de l'humour je crois qu'ils
ont tous à leur souris laser l'ancien
lanceur voilà il faut aussi la bat aussi
2 avril chez mme boulet de naples et de
voilà bon je dirais vous aurez peut-être
et en devoirs sept match toutes nos
regrets après cette page résultats en
passe maintenant à la chronique j'aime
j'aime pas de l'incroyable basile regoli
notre chroniqueur basé rigoli nous
présente ces tops et ses flops du
week-end à chaque émission
aujourd'hui donc on va passer aux
premiers gels jingle alors votre premier
j'aime concerne le football et maurepas
une fois de plus vous avez des actions
là bas vas-y oui mais il faut pas le
dire on arrive ça reste entre nous oui
pourquoi l'équipe de foot de mort parce
que effectivement on en reparle on en a
parlé à l'automne avec la coupe de
france mais on a parlé il ya un peu plus
d'un mois avec le championnat ils sont
toujours à un point du podium
et puis maintenant c'est la coupe des
yvelines ils ont gagné le week-end
dernier à chatou en quarts de finale
victoire nette et sans bavure 5 0 ce qui
est assez logique parce qu'ils étaient
supérieurs hiérarchiques - et voilà
l'ère on les retrouve maintenant en demi
finale ils ont ils vont affronter
guyancourt en demi finales l'objectif
est clair c'est d'aller chercher ce
titre
cette victoire en coupe des yvelines au
mois de juin pour pour finir en beauté
cette saison qui est très réussie parce
que c'est un club promu il ya deux ans
il évolue en deuxième division
départementale qui monte qui étaient
déjà là il ya en excellence où ils sont
maintenant il ya on va dire il ya 5 6
ans et est redescendu très vite en
deuxième division départementale il va
sur deux montées de suite
ils sont toujours en course pour aller
chercher cette deuxième place en
championnat donc tout va bien pour eux
ils ont ils ont intégré pas mal de
jeunes depuis deux trois ans à l'air de
porter leurs fruits donc coup de chapeau
à notamment à l'entraîneur christophe
rousset qui était arrivé qu'à récupérer
l'équipe quand elle était dans les
profondeurs de la 2e div et qui est en
train de faire un boulot remarquable
donc on leur souhaite de bien finir la
saison
finalement c'est peut-être la
préparation de la saison prochaine qui
se joue sur ces matches là revoilà la
montée clairement pas envisageable cette
année est ce que est ce que alexandre
est ce que
il faut préparer tout de suite la saison
prochaine de toute façon on est à une
période de recrutement
ça arrive je peux dire des conneries non
mais il est clair que de façon à 7 si on
ne peut plus jouer réellement la montée
à cette toxine championnat il est clair
qu'il faut commencer à compter les
joueurs qui comptent rester ou pas et en
fonction de ça et puis éventuellement
plus combler les manques on a qu'on a
trouvé dans la saison qui nous a
empêchés de monter donc c'est clair ça
se passe maintenant parce que les
recrutements
on m'avait déjà ils sont bien bien
avancé donc c'est vraiment un début
avril que ça commence à beaucoup de
temps dehors ces niveaux de compétition
dans les clubs belges disons nous
emballe un niveau comme ça je régionales
ou départementales on n'a pas droit à
plus de trois recrutements sur une
feuille de match dont tu peux en plus tu
veux le voir
donc tu imaginais un peu plus tôt un
turnover de trois personnes au niveau
national ces 5 et puis vint le monde
produit d'avant n'y a pas d'heure limite
n'est pas de mise mais finalement on
mord pas sur le parcours en coupe de
france souhaite viser un peu plus haut
sur mon en coupe de france voilà sens
parfois en coupe de france qu'ils
tournent enfin passé le leader
d'excellence celi mais qui caracole avec
avec plus de 15 points d'avance qui
réalise un véritable sans faute donc ça
aurait été 17 points voilà précisément
merci j'en savais c'était intouchable
cette année guy mais maintenant il ya
cette coupe des yvelines avec avec une
demi finale au mois de mai est peut-être
une finale au mois de juin qui va
permettre de garder tout le groupe et et
tous ses joueurs sous tension jusqu'à la
fin de saison on passe à présent
deuxième j'aime de basile jingle aussi
et il concerne l'eco-trail est en vie le
prochain qui s'était du strip mans la
compétition m'a dit tout à fait une
incroyable performance d'un ville
provient nicolas duel 25 ans il a
remporté l'eco trail de paris l'un des
dix trails de référence dans l'hexagone
pourquoi c'est une grande performance
déjà parce que l'eco trail c'est 80
kilomètres s'il n'avait jamais participé
à cette course jamais un trade une aussi
longue distance maintenant ils avaient
est petit avantage de bien connaître le
parcours pour s'entraîner dans les
yvelines est et en région parisienne
souvent
voilà c'est un bel exploit parce que au
départ il y avait quelques
référence du trails nationale dont
certains qui ont déjà participé à des
championnats du monde des championnats
d'europe et puis là il a réussi à tirer
son épingle du jeu sur un sur un
parcours qui est qu'ils maîtrisaient
comme sa poche
donc voilà coup de chapeau à nicolas
duel compétition qui est quand même
assez remarquable compétition très
difficile bas à 80 km de saint quentin
en yvelines à la tour eiffel avec des
marches à gravir jusqu'au premier étage
pour terminer c'est pour les premiers
c'est cinq heures six heures d'efforts
pour les derniers ses 10 11 heures ça se
termine de nuit donc c'est très
remarquable et il peut aller plus haut à
votre avis donc il connaissait bien il
peut aller plus haut on lui souhaite
maintenant le trade ça se court surtout
beaucoup en montagne surtout durant la
saison estivale
en habitant en région parisienne c'est
toujours compliqué de sacs limites et
s'acclimater à l'altitude à ses efforts
très très faim de montagne et les
courses on va dire dans la région lui
réussisse évidemment maintenant à voir
si sur des épreuves dans les pyrénées
dans les alpes il arrivera à rivaliser
avec avec avec ses habitués ces locaux
d'une règle soit par rapport à cette eco
trail loyal enfin moi c'est le type
d'épreuve que que j'aime beaucoup tout
ce qui est dépassement de soi même tout
ce qui est à 80 km web un sauvage est
quand même parti j'ai essayé de faire
les 24 heures du mans roller en solo
donc moi je me suis arrêté au bout de 14
heures d'efforts je ne digère pas
pendant l'effort donc c'est difficile de
courir sans s'alimenter
donc il ya énormément de riz nantes
paramètres à gérer sur sur ces
préparations qui sont très très longue
moi je vois là c'est des trucs
ces trucs que je trouve que je trouve
génial j'adore j'adore voir et discuter
avec ces sportifs qui sont des sportifs
complets et généralement très armes
puisque sans plus ce sont des
disciplines qui sont qui monte en
puissance mais qui sont quand même
encore un peu marre ce dont on vous
parle peu et du comité tease et voilà on
va passer à votre troisième j'aime
basile jingle il concerne le tennis le
tennis c'est une académie la all in
académie qui a vu le jour l'an dernier à
port marly donc dans le département on a
à côté de saint germain en laye beaucoup
de sûrement connaître ou ont connu
l'académie moratoglou qui était basé à
thiverval grignon à côté de plaisir créé
en 1996 depuis
elle a migré vers sophia antipolis dans
le sud de la france ça les conditions
sont meilleures
et voilà il ya une nouvelle académie
monté par thierry ascione l'ancien
joueur professionnel et des amis à lui
qui est également sur le circuit jérôme
haehnel marie gicquel qui l'ont rejoint
donc le but de cette académie ben voilà
c'est de proposer à des jeunes
franciliens et plus particulièrement des
yvelines ont avec elle et elle est basée
dans notre département la possibilité
d'accéder à du haut niveau une fois le
son cursus pour l'espoir police et que
l'on trouve à feucherolles terminé parce
qu'aujourd'hui une fois qu'on se
retrouve à 18 ans j'en avais déjà parlé
soit on fait partie des cracks français
et émouvant à l'insep où à roland garros
ou alors c'est la débrouille total donc
voilà c'est ça que j'aime en terre voilà
il ya cette académie qui puisse propose
ce à un coût évidemment mais voilà ça
aujourd'hui à calais fait les gros c'est
à peu près 18 mille euros l'année donc
ça cool c'est un investissement
maintenant c'est le prix à payer à
l'étranger pourquoi ça le seul pour
bénéficier d'une structure comme ça
pourquoi ça ne le serait pas en france
si on veut intégrer le circuit
professionnel de sortie possible c'est
comme comme disait vasile on en parlait
à quelques temps sur le fait que les
joueurs étaient un petit peu laissé tout
seul en autonomie il ya une petite élite
i just came réalité les nazis
supplémentaires et donc je sais pas mal
que justement il ya une suite parce
qu'il n'ya pas que le top 100 mondial
d'autres comptent continuer et qu'il
faut quand même accompagné sans qu'il
soit obligé de quitter la france ou de
quitter la région elle aurait pas de
leurs amis donc je trouve que c'est pas
mal que qu'il y ait des dés
des actions comme ça et en plus c'est
pas à mon avis ce n'est pas du bricolage
c'est quand même émis par des personnes
importantes comme thierry ascione qui
ont un bagage derrière eux et je pense
pas qu'ils vont faire un truc un peu
moyen je pense qu'il y avoir les moyens
qui devraient avoir du sérieux des gens
compétents et étant mieux que ça se
retrouve dans les yvelines et à faire un
petit bémol gens là dessus est ce qu'on
voit sur le fait que cette non le
premier robin le prix nom est le prix
voilà la vision du calcul est ce que
l'on voit c'est le tennis est ce un
parti encore des sports s'est pas donné
à tout le monde mais par contre moi je
vais mettre un petit bémol parce que
sportivement
sportivement on dira le dew tour de
table les meilleurs elles s'envoleront
une structure est symbole d'un des
complexes qui sont moment prévu pour eux
donc là est-ce que c'est pas quand même
aussi un petit moyenne de 2,2 de faire
plaisir à des jeunes qui finalement mes
frangins partie fn france jamet parti
fondé savoir c'est là qu'ils sortiront
et qui et kyron dans les meilleurs quoi
si c'est le cas
oui c'est intéressant sophie simplement
pour faire plaisir sur deux ou trois ans
au tennis c'est pas comme on espère qu
il ya très peu finalement deux joueurs
qui vivent réellement
professionnellement doit être tout à
fait de ce sport et à peut-être dit
français qui ont les bras morts que les
meilleurs mais les meilleurs son prix et
son ouïe déjà je pense qu'il y aura de
joueurs qui ont envie d'en vivre d'une
façon celui professionnel ou dans l'eure
avec un peu moins d'argent
un tout le monde produit avec des
millions ou des centaines de milliers
d'euros gilles avec quelques milliers
d'euros et donc il leur faut des
structures pour atteindre je pense ce
niveau là et c'est important qu'elles
qu'elles existent pour la mon sens avoir
avoir la sensation que j'ai toujours ce
cette histoire de se dire c'est pas
parce que on a passé un certain âge
qu'on ne peut pas se rêvait par la suite
voilà qui proviennent de sportifs qui
ont sorti les sources proches mais voilà
il ya des ja d'aider des jeunes dans
certains sports qui qui qui ne passe pas
qui passe inaperçu chez les cadets chez
les juniors et puis qui vont se révéler
un peu plus tard des histoires de dates
de naissance ou pour quelques jours près
bon c'était dans les catégories
inférieures il ya des histoires des
histoires comme ça et donc et bien la
maturité elle arrive un peu plus tard et
dans ces sports où les carrières sont
quand même très longue un rogers rogers
qui est toujours là et voilà donc et
bien quelqu'un qui peut arriver à 22 21
22 23 ans
moi ça ne me choquerait pas qu'on est
qu'ils soient passés vraiment au travers
des sélections des sélections
traditionnels après les gemmes on passe
au j'aime pas jing et on va parler de
versailles d'avoir premier j'aime pas
voilà le versailles
les clubs de sports collectifs
aujourd'hui si on si on fait un bilan
dans un club de versailles mais ça
n'empêche pas de faire un j'aime pas ça
sur versailles pourquoi parce qu'un
membre différent si si si l'équipe
senior de rugby de versailles venait à
descendre malheureusement en honneur ce
qui risque de se produire vu que la
situation semble bien difficile pour eux
on n'aurait que ça soit au foot au rand
au basket et au rugby plus aucune équipe
fanion un niveau national donc je pense
que c'est jamais arrivé parce que même
l'époque ou encore le club de rugby de
versailles il ya dix ans était en
honneur quand il était redescendu le
basket lui est encore en n3 donc on a
toujours eu au moins une équipe de sport
qu au niveau national à versailles et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand on
regarde les autres préfectures de région
parisienne balle à versailles ferait
figure d'exception aujourd'hui vous avez
nanterre le basket qui se dit
aujourd'hui donner une très bonne image
de la ville de nanterre vous avez pareil
à créteil avec le handball le foot
c'est un peu compliqué cette année voilà
exactement la noce ils sont bien traités
foot c'est compliqué voilà donc vous
voilà vous avez des préfectures quand
même qu'ils ont une bonne image grâce à
l'heure où plusieurs clubs sportifs et
aujourd'hui à versailles a dans les
yvelines
la préfecture n'a pas n'a pas un club
voilà au niveau national à temps et
comme c'est un petit j'aime pas mais
voilà mais comment expliquer cette
hausse comment l'expliquez vous basile
ça ne les intéresse
il ya des intéressements de la part des
politiques peut-être pour pour le sport
à versailles oui tout à fait tout à fait
il n'ya pas il n'y a pas ce projet
d'avoir un un club sportif de haut
niveau pour faire parler de la ville
parce qu'il ya il n'y a pas besoin tout
simplement parce que effectivement il ya
le château de versailles donc il ya le
tourisme
on connaît déjà que ça soit en france au
niveau mondial versailles par un autre
moyen que qu'à travers le sport ericsson
vous qui côtoyez des des élus car ça y
est nous ces données on a été la seule
équipe à être augmentée dans le bas
comparé au taux de sport donc j'ai pas
critiqué l'algérie et cette année alors
que tu es descendu
voilà maintenant c'était aussi un petit
peu notre attente puisque on était moins
bien lotis voilà donc c'était on a un
peu réorganiser rétabli un peu le
quitter entre les différents sports
voilà maintenant la difficulté c'est que
en tout cas moi je le vois handball
il ya de plus en plus de bons joueurs de
plus en plus de bonnes équipes qui a
plus en plus de licenciés plus en plus
de joueurs payés à des niveaux de plus
en plus bas et donc il est difficile de
se maintenir un niveau national ou d'y
accéder et bien évidemment moi ans dans
tous les cas ce n'était pas un politique
de payer des joueurs au niveau régional
mais mais il n'empêche quand on joue
contre des équipes ont des joueurs qui
sont payés et est donc forcément ça leur
permet d'attirer un certain type de
joueur qui à mon sens n'apporte pas les
valeurs du sport parce que probablement
un petit peu trop mercenaires pas
forcément pour tous mais pour certains
donc mais il n'empêche qu'ils attirent
un certain nombre de joueurs qui
évoluent et soit en pro avant soit en
semi-pro quand même faut quand même
souligner alors qu'on est au niveau
régional donc donc c'est pas ce n'est
pas évident et c'est sûr c'est pas
évident je ne pense pas que la position
de la ville de versailles va changer
puisque comme on l'a dit ils ont
suffisamment de renommée mondiale avec
le château et c'est connu dans le monde
entier et c'est pas c'est pas comme 18
comme créteil où il brille pour nous
prenons ça qu'ils n'ont que le sport
pour rayonner dans la france seulement
un truc qu'on avait déjà relevé ici est
ce que toi tu le ressens au niveau du en
août pareil c'est à dire que nos jeunes
que l'on peut former sur toute la
période scolaire et qui quand ils
arrivent à la sortie du lycée sont
obligés de partir dans des écoles à
droite à gauche sur le caractère
français alors naturellement à une
formation donc y aller la nature est
elle à ce problème dû au fait que nous
accueillerons plus au delà de pas
pouvoir éventuellement avoir une somme
d'argent plus importante pour
éventuellement recruter des gens
allaient payer ses gardes c'est surtout
on a du mal à garder les jeunes qui ont
un niveau correct pour ce pour ce niveau
voilà près d'athènes 3 mais qu'on voit
rennes 2 1 mais qui de par leurs études
sont absents une partie des équipes de
jeunes
ça donne quoi il ya les écarts les ça
donne quoi les résultats justement des
équipes de jeunes c'est plutôt correct
on risque qui sont performantes de jeu
de basket servant à la dernière on a vu
les jeunes qui avaient des champions de
france dans cette histoire de
coopération avec maurepas et et poissy
le foot également les u19 sont
aujourd'hui plus haut niveau il faut il
faut il faut pas regarder vos stops sur
versailles que par les équipes seniors
n'en faut regarder le sport on n'a pas
l'équipe de jeunes qui elle se danse et
sport dès qu'il ya vraiment un joueur
qui sort du lot dans les catégories de
jeunes ce soit au rugby au foot voilà
par opg sa part au racing au rugby parce
que toute façon derrière ils savent que
arrive lancé dans là aussi le niveau ne
sera pas intéressant pour permettre à
leur potentiel comme j'aime c'est ça qui
est dommage pour son associé on passe à
votre d'année j'aime pas basile jingle
et on va parler de handball et de
l'équipe du chéné puis petit à petit
semaine après semaine
oui alex est revenue aujourd'hui sur le
plateau donc j'ai pas j'ai pas osé
parler de verser du club de versailles
de handball non sérieux sérieusement ça
voilà c'est le chesnay le chêne qui
était remonté cette saison
en n2 avec soi disant un joli projet en
faisant confiance aux jeunes justement
qui avait perdu permis cette remontée n3
n2 est également recrutant des joueurs
qui devaient apporter leur expérience et
puis voilà cette mayonnaise n'a pas pris
il ya une défaite ce week-end contre
l'avant dernier
donc j'y vois là qui leur confient leur
conflit avec la tâche voilà s'il perd
s'ils perdaient il se mettait vraiment
un grosse épine dans le pied
la situation voilà c'est fait que
aujourd'hui un but voilà il ya un
prochain match bien logés au match la
semaine prochaine contre saint maur et
le premier nouveau les premiers non
relégables voilà c'est à quitte ou
double soit il le gagne et il se donne
encore un petit espoir sur les dernières
journées soit ils le perdent et voilà
mois d'avril dès le mois d'avril
ils sont condamnés à retourner en n3
donc on fait une année en n2 il y aura
je pense en bas des enseignements et
attiré 2 de cet échec
alexandre c'est finalement cette équipe
du shérif faire un flop s'attaquer au
problème
comme l'a dit il ya eu un recrutement de
cinq joueurs au final il y en a surtout
un qui est performant elle si ces
français et les certains qui est comme
une yole qui ne joue même plus donc
voilà savoir qu'il ya quand même un
fossé entre la n3 la n2 et donc si on se
goure son recrutement bat derrière c'est
compliqué je suis compliqué et et puis
après voilà la mauvaise dynamique ses
deux fils de s'en relever etc et et donc
ils en reviennent à perdre un but un
match qui qu'ils soient là qui tout à
fait à leur portée
maintenant bon mathématiquement ce n'est
pas encore fini 1
mais l'espoir est là on peut dire ça
comme ça on continue à présent cette
émission par notre rubrique débats
on passe à notre débat du jour il
concerne le cyclisme sur piste
un an après les cinq médailles d'or
glanées au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lors des
championnats du monde les français n'ont
pas su résister à leur exploit à londres
début mars françois pervis qui ne
s'était pas aligné sur le kilomètre a
perdu en 16e de finale dans l'épreuve de
vitesse individuelle et lors des
épreuves de kerim grégory baugé
originaire de maisons laffitte n'a pas
franchi le seuil des quarts de finale en
vitesse évinois est également reparti
sans les médailles sur les épreuves de
vitesse par équipes
pour expliquer cette désillusion chez
nos champions certains évoquent des
problèmes entre grégory baugé et
françois pervis les deux stars du sprint
français
faut-il faire un choix entre les deux
pour les jo vous votez oui non peut-il
faire un choix
on n'a pas le choix parce qu'on n'a pas
le choix ou de choisir entre les deux
pour les youyous ont voté massivement
voté oui non fautif en question après on
peut peut-être fait un pas peut-être ya
possibilité d'en aligner un sur la
vitesse 1 sur les quais rinne la
problématique c'est qu'ici on en a un
sur les terrains en avignon ces deux
coureurs sur la vitesse sur le keirin
ils sont obligés de courir ensemble pour
la vitesse par équipes et donc du coup
si la mésentente mauvaise entente entre
ces deux coureurs ça peut peut être
préjudiciable
il ya yahia ne sont pas deux passes
après pour moi l'un des premiers soucis
c'est quand même que grégory n'est plus
le meilleur démarreur mondiale une fan
des plus partie des murs démarreur
mondiale mondiaux par monde depuis
depuis deux ans maintenant
il avait pas fait un super chrono
51 année dernière il avait quand même
réussi avec des très belles performances
de kevin sireau et michael d'almeida sur
les deuxième et troisième tours réussi à
obtenir le titre de champion du monde
cette année ça n'a pas été le cas parce
que ben grec perd quasiment une demi
seconde sur par rapport à l'eau aux
meilleurs chronos des anglais sur le
premier tour n'ont pas été champions du
monde non plus mais mais voilà c'est
vrai que là il ya quand même un gros
problème sûr sûr sûr cette vitesse par
équipes et sur le règlement des jeux
olympiques et qui nous pose qui nous
pose une problématique maintenant
maintenant voilà est-ce que est ce que
nous nos coaches n'ont pas la
possibilité de leurs affaires
remettre leur amour-propre de côté pour
pour aller chercher ce qu'ils veulent
tous et avoir un titre de champion
olympique
ben il ya un moment où il va falloir
falloir bosser et travailler dans de
bonnes conditions quoi mais là
maintenant on est quand même très très
près les élections tu te reposes seuil
at-il pas un jeune con conduisait si
bien sûr un problème c'est que tu
l'alignera pas après sur un kérinou sur
une blessure non je ne sais pas mais moi
je passe en sébastien maintenant dont
sébastien vigier sébastien vigier qui
est vice championne du monde juniors il
ya deux ans fait en ce moment à peu près
les mêmes temps que que grégory voire un
peu meilleur que grégory sur sur
certains entraînements donc oui bien sûr
mais le problème c'est qu'on peut pas
l'envoyer aux jeux olympiques comme ça
c'est impossible
alexandre elle a pas l'expérience pour
l'heure apple app expérience comment
est-ce qui va gérer le moment du départ
sur une manche au championnat du haut
chemin c'est là où je suis pas d'accord
mais d'un point de vue général quel que
soit le sport pour moi l'expérience on
s'en fout si tu es meilleur tu joues
points et moi je leur ai dit aux gens je
leur ai essayé je l'aurais amar la place
de sélectionneur je leur ai essayé au
championnat du monde
yaya ya quinze jours oui ça se prépare à
vendre sous la surface
on parle d'une mauvaise ambiance dans
l'équipe de france dû notamment au fait
que entre grégory baugé et françois
pervis le climat soit vraiment très
tendu entre entre les deux au point
qu'ils ne se parlent même même plus du
tout de ce que de ce que j'entends
est ce qu on pourrait même imaginer
qu'elle de tn n'en prennent pas un des
deux ne sélectionne pas un des deux pour
les jeux qui restaient fortes chances
qu'ils n'aillent pas au jeu
et les deux noms banon enfin grégory
grégory pour moi il est y voit là il a
eu le titre united il ya eu dit il ya
deux ans en vitesse individuelle en
préparant est vraiment disant voilà jeu
j'aurai le titre cette année et il a
réussi à avoir le titre
il a réussi à avoir ce titre de champion
du monde pour moi il est incontestable
sur sur les vitesses sur la vitesse
individuelle qui seraient pris
l'entraînement si c'était pas un alpage
de grégory beaud bâle 2e le deuxième
pour moi c'est françois mais le problème
c'est que la france soit il a fait des
n'a pas fait de performances aux
championnats du monde il a fait des
temps il a fini tant qu'ils sont en deçà
de ce qu'il a mais oui il a fait plus de
dix secondes
il a fait plus de dix secondes je joue
l'agent qui avec le temps d'anciens
juniors et meilleur jeu le nous et je
suis même pas sûr qu'avec le temps qu'il
a fait aux championnats du monde à
londres cette année il aurait été
qualifié au pour le tournoi de vitesse
donc cinquante années de jeunes eurent
donc
c'est toujours de la faute
je veux bien assumer et prendre en
prendre la responsabilité
françois pervis en tout cas six fois
champion du monde je le rappelle quand
même avons tous très envie d'aller aux
jeux évidemment nous l'avions sûr il ya
quelques semaines
ça représente le graal quand on est
champion olympique
on change c'est c'est c'est
interplanétaire c'est c'est quasiment
indescriptible parce que là là ça me
fait sortir de l'anonymat pour un sport
comme le mien qui est pas forcément très
connus et puis on n'est pas connue que
seulement des cyclistes dans le monde
entier on est connu de toute la
population mondiale quand tu es champion
olympique et tu pas sur toutes les télés
du monde aux prises la lada pistard au
final il ya main bah ouais mais est-ce
que envers l'équipe s'il faut l'enlever
moi je pense que l'équipe avec françois
pervis et leur est dû être monté il ya
beaucoup plus longtemps parce que pour
moi françois été
l'élément à
l'élément indiscutable en troisième
position même si c'est vrai qu'à ce
moment là michael faisait déjà des
faisait il faisait de ce sont les
meilleurs temps les meilleurs chronos
mondiaux
mais c'est vrai que dans l'optique des
jeux olympiques de 2002 2016 et cette
équipe aurait déjà dû être monté il ya
très longtemps on n'aurait pas dû se
dire on verra à quatre mois des jeux
pour pour faire la sélection donc donc
là c'est vrai que les garçons sont dans
des dans des schémas tactiques ou dans
des schémas de réflexion dans le sommet
de préparation qui sont pas qu'ils sont
pas optimum je pense que leur leur leur
réflexion n'est pas n'est pas bonne
réponse lundi non moi je dirais répond
oui répond ce lundi pour la sélection
est pour moi la plus grosse réponse à
toutes ces interrogations on l'aura on
l'aura au mois d'août au mois d'août
quand quand on verra les résultats qui
seront établies parce que ça n'empêche
que comprennent grigori même si on
aligne la veille l'équipe grégory kévin
sireau et michael d'almeida
je suis pas sûr qu'il soit champion
olympique et je suis pas sûr que même si
grégory peut être champion olympique en
vitesse par et envisage individuel sur
le terrain on aura personne donc on à
françois pervis et grégory baugé l'autre
grégory baugé qui a quand même neuf
titres de champion du monde mais qui n'a
jamais été champion olympique et qui
veulent être cette année on écoute
champion olympique c'est un objectif de
carrière comme c'était le cas pour venu
afin d'être champion du monde donc il ya
une case qui n'est pas coché donc voilà
c'est ce qui me pousse les matins
et alors que j'aimerais bien rester au
lit me surpasser entraînements
c'est vrai que chez nous en france on a
un très fort potentiel donc aussi ses 6
pouces à ne pas faiblir face à mes
camarades et politiques publiques ou bof
ans alexandre si on doit faire un choix
vous prenez qui moi comme je dis je
prends le junior est recalé de bouger ça
bouge et juniors pour vous y aurez même
basile très bonne équipe avec un julio
jr en premier greg en deux et françois
calvet 103e je pense qu'entre baugé
pervis il y en a un des deux qui ne sera
pas dans la sélection et vous prenez
quelqu'un dit si vous devez reprendre
je ne suis pas dtn mon courage dtn pour
les quatre jours qui lui restent
ça bravo parce que moi je pense que
sportivement si les deux sont capables
sportivement adjointe anne d'aller
chercher une médaille est là il faut
quand même qu'ils mettent un peu lent
recueil de leur côté deux côtés et
dédiant ses gains pour le bien-être de
la discipline en france fêtera du tour
ea - voilà une médaille olympique auquel
il court après depuis des années qu'on
aurait pourtant quelques jours en tout
cas avant lui toujours c'est un peu le
même choix que pour le dtm 9,1 pour
didier deschamps au foot sérieux là ils
ont trop de très bons on a du choix
on a du choix ces données dans notre
situation on passe maintenant à notre
défi du jour
le défi concerne aujourd'hui le baseball
équipes seniors masculines des cougars
de montigny-le-bretonneux s'est prêté au
jeu
le but visé dans un cercle à une
distance de 20 m après avoir tourné la
tête en bas ce n'est pas simple et très
drôle regarder benjamin schmid l'air
numéro 25
je joue depuis maintenant une douzaine
d'années premières bases lanceur voilà
je m'appelle feng shui 3 intime mathieu
dufour je suis cougar depuis 22 ans
maintenant et on m'appelle du ruf est
bon je joue en son centre
tony jadas je suis et chants aux cougars
depuis 6 8 ans maintenant
oliveux berrebi donc chaud club depuis
bonjour noces et billère pour la chaux
toujours
d'où vient ce dernier traque au hockey
de sic ou bien on y va
très bien
m
on
on est là en présence c'est avant tout
une histoire d'équipé plaisir d une
belle victoire d'équipé
j'avais vraiment des concurrents
un excellent niveau et c'est vrai que
voir pour la famille et pour la pole
club avec qui avait un peu de tout on
avait les petits les chauves les grands
et des relevés de kerhollo les gens à la
police et yala par rapport à certains
défis qui était au lit mais je vais pas
le jeune âge je trouve qu'ils ont ils
sont vraiment mises et c'était pas ça
vous a plu
très bien géré les voir sur un match
genre à des tractions c'était super
sympa
oui j soir droit comme le respect équipe
et un budget américain il avait une
petite soeur prochain dans le procès
qu'elle a certains qui ont aussi aux
yankees peut-être à la fin 2010 je viens
tu johnny qui alors c'est new york merci
à vous en tout cas merci pour ces débats
enflammés
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve donc
dans quinze jours le jeudi 14 avril pour
un nouveau numéro de sion par les sports
très belle soirée sur tv fil 78